apps typically have their own storage
they're using Facebook's API to ask for
your data and then they take it and
process it and store it and they
probably conform to their country's data
storage laws but Facebook's not keeping
that information you've given it to a
company for them to take away yeah and
that's why you have to cut out those
companies and say please delete my data
we actually give away a lot of data
without really thinking about it and
this has come up in the news recently
because there's a company in Cambridge
and let's go who've used some data from
an app that was built by a professor at
a university for a research reason and
then the date has been passed on and on
and on is interesting to talk about how
apps offer your data around or when the
be they when people build an app what
they want from you and why did they
build it was the biggest question
because there's no many reason they
built these apps how easy is it to make
all these apps is it is it a complicated
process it's pretty super easy and
they've got example code snippets on
Facebook's developer site and you pretty
much copy and paste those lines of code
in and change what you do after you get
the permission they've basically built a
framework that makes it easy for you to
ask for types of data and then to get
permissions from user for that type of
data without having to do much coding so
first of all I say there's two major
types of situation that we tend to get
into one is where you've used Facebook
to log into another website and actually
yeah we should acknowledge we're not
just talking about Facebook here the
most social media platforms have one of
these API is to log in with Twitter log
in with Google and and that's a common
thing that a lot of us do because it
makes everything super convenient the
other type of way we do this is that we
install these kind of fun little apps
like a little quiz to know how much we
know about kittens or a little app which
gives you a tag cloud of the most
commonly used words you use in all of
your posts or which celebrity do you
look most like and then it takes your
facebook picture and then merges it with
the celebrities as you look a little bit
like some celebrity that you want to
look like but in order to do those
things like generate a word cloud of
your posts or to take your Facebook
image and merge it with a celebrity they
have to ask for information about you or
get access to your data and we should
think a little bit about why they did
that
and that's probably the question we
should ask ourselves more and haven't
done a lot of the time why would someone
want to build an app which creates a tag
cloud of all of your posts they might be
interested in analyzing lots of posts to
know what sort of things people talk
about and so they they then want a
reason for you to give them the posts
like you wouldn't say yeah sure I'll
give my data to that company that
company they go why would someone want
to give us all of the posts we could
generate a word cloud for them and that
would be a nice thing that they would
get benefit from and we would get
benefit from the upfront about what
they're doing with your data they should
be and they have to be more upfront
about it now in 2014 Facebook added a
kind of permissions request process for
review so now when you write an app and
submit it they then look at why did you
ask for the data of what you intend to
use it for but then after you've said
yes it then goes on to how trustworthy
they are as a company so they they might
have very well said why they wanted to
access it and it might be that when it
pops up and ask for information it says
we want to use this data
his linked away and but most people like
all the terms of collisions just so say
yeah yeah sure so go ahead and actually
it's very scary to see what Facebook
thinks you like I had a quick look on
the things it gives me adverts for and
it was alcohol parenting and animals so
in that order as well so I'm obviously
tweeting too much about the wine bar
that we like and once you've given that
permission is that in perpetuity though
is that forever or is that just to now
that's so it varies a little bit about
what you give it permission for and
whether you give it historical
information about all your posts or just
things you can't you like but then once
they've got that they're then bound by
data loss which we're not gonna go too
far into in this but they should if you
ask them to delete your data which is
partly where this question came from in
the current news topic but really once
you've given it to them you have to
proactively ask them to delete it so
when they write an app like that they
have to request using the sample lines
of code to access certain types of data
and one thing is a little bit scary is
that
anything that's public about you
they don't need reviewed by Facebook so
your public profile they can anybody
create an app which will access your
public profile and you can say yes
install it - and Facebook doesn't check
it because it's just accessing the
public information that you have public
on Facebook there's a few things I've
learned I've learned that there's a
whole lot of apps I did not know I gave
my data to so if at some point just
stepped over this and let's do it this
there's random ones like piggy share and
I don't really know what piggy shared
those but for some reason that knows all
of my friends impose on my posts and
it's looked at them some of them I
definitely used for a good reason like
Spotify I have in there and I want it to
be there because it's somehow
interaction of my social interest in
music and actually what you can do is if
you go to settings and then the settings
section go to apps you can see every
single app that you've given permission
to what information you've given it and
whether or not you're allowing it to
post and if it is posting who can see
those posts whether it's your friends
everybody or just you and you can edit
all of those things so you can now go
back and say actually I don't want you
to see this information so if that's
information that's not yet happened like
the things you will like over the next
few weeks you can from this point stop
those apps seeing that information in
the future however if you delete an app
or take away permissions Facebook then
clearly says to you we've taken away
permission from this app to use that
data or see that data but it's up to you
to ask that company to delete your
information Facebook has no control to
make that company necessarily delete it
it says you have to do it so you have to
find the people who created the app
contact them and say please delete what
you have about me which is a scary
situation you find yourself in where you
realize you have to manually contact 30
companies to say you've got information
about me which I don't really want you
to have anymore please delete it and
then you just have to hope those
companies conform to data protection
laws and then will delete it is that
country reliant though I mean might they
freely ignore you because they're based
somewhere else upon bury yeah I should
that's that's another computer file
video on privacy law I think the
scariest thing is probably that when an
app asks for your information
facebook allows you to give away what
you know about other people to the app
to experience the app so it might say we
want information about all of your
friends and so there's a section on
there which is the scariest thing I
found for me and I guess I kind of knew
this but it's interesting to see it now
it's a setting that you can control if
it's not too late it's too late for all
the things that people have your friends
have given away about you so far but you
can say I will let my friends give
information about me to other apps for
this type of information your religious
views your birthdays your family and
relationships what things you like that
type of information which you allow all
of your friends to see and therefore you
allow your friends to give that
information to other apps and so while
we log into Facebook you can see a list
of all of the apps you've installed and
what date you've given them you can't
see a list of all of the apps that your
friends have given your data to and you
don't know what data that necessarily is
or what they've asked for but yes may be
someone that you're closely friends with
us who's got access to a pretty much an
unvetted version of your Facebook has
maybe giving away lots of aspects of
your data to other companies so one
thing you can do right now if you want
to stop this happening more is you can
go into the settings and then the apps
bit of the settings and your apps others
use is what it's called
there's a checkbox list of all the
things that you allow apps that other
people use to see about you and you can
go straightaway done tick all of those
it might be that you become not included
in there who your 10 closest friends
type apps but but maybe you feel better
about having protected your data it's
kind of thing you should do every few
months is review what you've
purposefully are accidentally given
information to and whether you want to
re restrict that and hopefully those
companies then abide by removal laws
effectively but we need a whole other
computer pal video on privacy laws
properly trust oaths or Pfeiffer was
something that programmers and
communications engineers understand very
very well so we went and wrote some
software which does a five for tens of
the blockchain and so whenever coins are
stolen and put in a transaction